Шановні колеги немає більш важливого
завдання для Верховної Ради України ніж
підтримка збройних сил України і коли в
цій залі говорять що на армію немає
грошей це неправда сьогодні буде
розглядатися ще один законопроект де як
мінімум два мільярди гривень з
брехливого марафону з російськомовно не
англійську мовного а російськомовного
дому іфридаму можна передати на збройні
сили України і ми будемо це вимагати
зробити і можна передати ці кошти саме
на повернення 30 тисяч ми не знаємо
навіщо пансабль подав цю блокуючу
Постанову і чому сьогодні є не виносять
до сесійної зали України ми не знаємо
чому так само потім було зупинено в
першому читанні голосування за закон
який повертав 30 000 відбулася дійсно
маніпуляція коли між першим і другим
читанням до закону яким ми зараз
розглядаємо внесені норми які погіршують
тіло цього закону дійсно європейська
Солідарність боролися за те щоб
поранення отримували не 600 гривень а 20
тисяч гривень щоб Курсанти строковики
отримували не 800 гривень А 6 тисяч і
2,500 грн щоб можливо була мобілізація і
демобілізація щоб можливо була насправді
встановлення справедливості щодо героїв
бузкового гаю які на відміну від
прокурорів СБУ не втекли з окупованого
Херсону а виконували бойові завдання не
встигнувши ще отримати навіть військовий
квиток і загинули і щоби вони отримали
справедливі почесті після своєї загибелі
дуже важливо що ми повертаємо
справедливість щодо інструкторів і
щосили тероборони не будуть направлятися
на фронт без навчання це в цьому законі
є але на жаль навіть не робоча група а в
оцій між робочою групою хтось Можливо
навіть не з Верховної Ради України
внесли е-е тези які перекреслюють тисяч
і тому наша фракція буде вимагати
повернення оцього абзацу про виплату
всім військовим тридцяти тисяч в
редакції 1-го читання колеги це важливо
військові дивляться сьогодні на наші
голосування військові нам довіряють і ми
маємо бути гідними їх довіри давайте
повернемо 30 000 військовим а дійсно
Кабміну дозволимо їх розпорядженням
забрати будь-які виплати в прокурорів
які Вибачте військових
воєнкоматів які сидять в тилу і
корупціонують там в тих хто не має
відношення до бойових дій ніхто не
проходить злагодження на перегонах але
ці теми ми маємо з вами вирішити тому
наша фракція буде ставити на
підтвердження в ті поправки які
погіршують тіло закону щодо виплати
30,000 грн це абсолютно ганьба і
відповідальність за це лежить на
конкретних депутатах і конкретних
фракціях соромно